did you know that David Ortiz was once
an afterthought in a trade as a ptb l or
a player to be names later Big Papi was
barely even considered in a deal between
the Seattle Mariners and the Minnesota
Twins ptb and L trades are usually done
to delay the final terms for teams that
are still deciding the role of the
players on their roster after being
drafted by Seattle or t showed steady
Improvement in the miners but his stint
was short-lived he was widely recognized
as a raw Prospect with decent selecting
potential at best the team traded him
away to Minnesota as a ptbnl in a move
that normally results in minimal impact
the switch didn't pan out and the twins
later released Big Papi once the Boston
Red Sox took a chance on him the rest
would be history he'd go on to be deemed
one of the best Sluggers in history and
aided Boston and ending its 86-year
World Series drought David Ortiz's Pat
to stardom might have been considered a
long shot at best but sometimes the best
Talons are Best Kept hidden